[Music]
recently earned a Golden Globe
nomination for her role in the hit movie
hustlers and an Oscar nomination could
be next that would be her first believe
it or not but she told me in an
interview for CBS Sunday morning that
she feels like she's already won after
being invited to perform the Super Bowl
halftime show in February rehearsals are
underway what does it mean it's like
winning the Oscar it's the biggest show
that there is it has the biggest
audience it's you get to have like this
big production like we you don't get to
do that on tour you know everything it's
like budget-conscious and you can do
this and you can do that and it's a
different experience and I think it's
just like a fantasy for all musical
artists to be able to play the Super
Bowl and have like that 12 minutes of an
amazing show and I don't know there's
just something exhilarating about it had
you ever performed with Shakira before
no no I've never done any I've never
even done a song with Shakira but now
you're rehearsing together no we're not
rehearsing together she's doing her show
I'm doing my show but we're gonna do
something together
I don't know I don't know we haven't
gotten there yet
I think we both just started kind of
rehearsing our own songs for right now
English Spanish I think with us you can
expect that you know like combination of
that all right that's a little of both
hold something man okay I mean it's in
Miami you know and we're both Latin
artists we bring that flavor and I think
that's gonna be exciting and a new thing
that you know hasn't been on any other
Super Bowl no it hasn't and I was pretty
fun wait to see no I'm looking forward
to it you know she's actually kind of a
student of Super Bowl show she remembers
in 1996 Diana Ross show or she left the
stadium in a helicopter yes that's right
and we got to go to rehearsals I cannot
divulge anything that we saw did you
sign it you know very excited it's not
disclosure he may be a big performance
but did you get to see a different
Jennifer she's now 50 years old I so
admire her number one she's stunningly
gorgeous but she's so smart and she's so
strategic and there are many sides to
the woman that we know is Jennifer Lopez
oh absolutely so she is now 50 with new
purse back
wisdom and doing some of the best work
of her career so in the interview one of
the more fascinating things is is if all
you know about her is supermarket
tabloids and music videos so she's a
genuine after an artist right I think
you're heard think about process talk
about how she put the role in a row in
hustlers together I think it's gonna
change a lot of people viewer yeah I
really do the stakes are high on that
Super Bowl show because with all those
people washing you know it's like one
small thing goes wrong and everybody
knows about it but I think she rises to
the challenge of that oh she loves a
t-bone kinda nervous about it she knows
well I mean she's a human being I think
she's nervous but she thrives off of
that yeah she puts herself in these
sorts of situations I mean she's had a
huge year and that's gonna be a capstone
I start to another big year did you talk
to her about turning 50 because I think
she has said it vlad jennifer lopez to
set a new standard for what fit out good
fifty looks we did i mean it's it's a it
makes me feel old to look at her and
then you're 50 yeah what's happening
here yeah no it was great so i'm looking
forward to that and my full interview
with jennifer lopez will be this weekend
on CBS Sunday morning I can't wait for
that too
you